what do you are
the pros the strengths of Donald Trump
Trump's strengths are mostly superficial
and in terms of presentation
Trump was able to I I call it a grift
some on the right say he's just so good
at relating to different types of people
Trump as a rich guy from New York City
was able to convince people that he
spent most of his life trying to be kept
isolated from that he had their best
interests in mind that he knew why they
weren't doing well in the 2016 economy
and that he had solutions that he was
going to bring forward the truth is
he never really liked those people and
as soon as they weren't useful to him
for a brief period of time he you know
that that love affair with his followers
stopped and then now it's back that he
needs them again